Mariah Carey learned about the Las Vegas
mass shooting right before a live TV
interview I pray for the victims and I
hope that all this can stop as soon as
possible the singer was live via
satellite on good morning Britain just
moments after news broke of a fatal
shooting at the route 91 harvest Country
Music Festival in Las Vegas on Sunday
night I spent a lot of time in Vegas and
just everything happening anywhere is a
huge tragedy the Grammy winner who has a
residency at Caesar's Palace in Sin City
was promoting her Christmas tour when
the host Piers Morgan switched gears to
address the attack at Mandalay Bay
Resort and hotel during Jason Aldean's
performance it's terrible because people
are just going out to listen to music
and and you know that's what they want
to do and and they're really it's just
you know they're they're out for the
night and then something shocking like
this happened the songbird sent out a
heartfelt tweet after the interview
writing quote horrified to hear about
the shooting in hashtag Las Vegas my
thoughts are with the victims and their
families praying for everyone's safety
peers also took to Twitter to respond to
critics who said it was unprofessional
to ask Mariah about the attacks quote we
told Mariah's people before the
interview her reaction seemed very
relevant given she's a performer who
often has residents in Vegas
[Music]